Are you on a you on YouTube?
>> Yeah.
What's up, fellas? What's up? Are y'all
Muslims? I'm assuming.
>> Oh my goodness, I know you, bro. Yeah.
>> Y'all on YouTube, right? Yeah, yeah,
yeah. What's up, guys? So, we're going
around campus as asking the Muslims why
we should Your sign is upside down, bro.
Goodness, man. Forget this.
We're talking about why should we
believe Muhammad? Would you guys like to
give what maybe your best reason why we
should believe Muhammad?
Nah, I'm okay. Okay, you're okay? Y'all
don't want to Y'all don't want to give
us your reason? Nah, we don't want to
have a You're just going to be wasting
your time, so Why Why would you say
that?
>> Cuz you talked to one of my good friends
before, so I feel like
you already talked to him. Ain't nothing
you can get from me, you know?
>> I don't Wait, I don't understand that.
>> We have ours. You know what I mean?
Free is your religion for us is ours.
What What What exactly does that mean
though for like discourse of if somebody
who's who's seeking Islam or getting
some information?
>> We see you online and stuff. You did
this like
You're a respectful dude, you know what
I mean?
>> Yeah.
I'll put There's There's quite people
there They got a stand over there.
Where? Go inside the union.
They got a Islam stand over there. You
probably talk to them over They're set
up right now? Yeah. Okay. Okay, sure.
Yeah, we'll we'll talk to
we'll we'll go talk to somebody with the
stand up. Yeah, y'all take care, man.
Okay, we'll try. What's up, y'all? I
like the shirt, man. Thank you.
>> you, man. What's up, y'all? I GOT TO LET
WHAT'S UP, Y'ALL?
>> [laughter]
>> Y'ALL Y'ALL STUDENTS UP HERE?
>> YEAH. SO, we have a college campus
ministry.
>> Mhm. We got to go out and evangelize
right now. It's crazy that we just ran
That's crazy. Look at that. LOOK AT
THAT.
That's insane. Can I see this? Yeah. So,
what we got here? We got Breath of
Revival Worship and Prayer Night. Okay.
I ain't mad at y'all. Friday night.
>> What brings you to OC? Uh just trying to
get to do some ministry, man. Trying to
find some Muslims to talk to and give
them the gospel, so
So, is it Is this building right here?
We talked to them We talked to them last
week. They They brought you up. I wrote
it. They brought me up? Why are
[laughter] we catching strays, bro? I'll
be minding of my own business, man.
Goodness, can I talk about Jesus? Good.
So yeah, if you just walk in straight
those doors and straight across you'll
see them on the right.
>> I'm I'm a little hard with directions.
So is it this building to my left or is
it straight?
Okay.
>> [laughter]
>> Like this is even more cuz we're just
praying for revival on campus. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. A lot of us have just been
trying to well one spread the gospel and
then one just bring
>> Yeah. that realness back.
>> For sure, for sure.
That's what I'm talking about.
Can I ask you a quick question real
quick? What does like your prayer life
look like for evangelists, like
evangelists specifically? Oh, well, it's
I have my time in the mornings, you
know, usually my time in the mornings.
That's when I, you know, have most of my
time to be alone with the Lord, you
know? And
then like when I'm on the way,
obviously, I'll just, you know, be in
prayer mode,
you know, praying that the Holy Spirit
goes before me and, you know, reaches
the hearts that I would come in contact
with and just be able to plant the seed,
you know, so it's all it's all up to God
at the end of the day, man. All we do is
plant seeds, right? We ain't convincing
nobody. It says ask a Muslim. All right,
cool.
Yeah, yeah.
>> [laughter]
>> Thank you guys. Appreciate you.
A lot of people have already spoken with
you and we spoke with you at homeless
day so
>> I've never spoken to you before. I
understand but my friend spoke to you.
I'm going to say the So so so you're so
you're on the same program as them. You
say you put up a sign say ask a Muslim.
You draw Christians over here to have
the discussion to say no to a
knowledgeable Christian who knows your
religion. I understand but we already
spoke with you. You didn't speak with
me. You know, this is my first time
here. I just met these brothers and
sisters for the first time and they told
me, "Hey, there's a dawah table in
there. They'll talk to you."
I understand. All right, here's my
disappointment. Muslims got a dawah
table up here. They say, "Hey Muslims,
hey people, come ask questions about
Islam." We come ask questions about
Islam. They say, "No, we don't want to
talk to you because you know you know
too much. We we we We appreciate it.
Yeah, you did.
You know that I know you're religious so
you don't want to talk. No, I just spoke
with you. No, you never spoke with me. I
spoke with you ask me anything.
>> You
you never spoke with me. Hey, he keeps
saying he spoke to you. Yeah, we spoke
to you before.
>> [laughter]
>> This is insane. Brother, it's You can't
tell us you spoke to us. That that that
doesn't make any sense.
With who? With you?
Show Yeah, show us the pictures. It is
doesn't make any It says ask a Muslim we
come ask a Muslim and no, we don't want
to talk to you. Yeah, Jesus is a Muslim
though.
Is that you? No, no, this is my friend.
Okay, so we never spoke to you before.
No, you haven't spoke to me. I didn't
say directly it's me, but I'm saying
that you've already spoken to us as a
Muslim. What what what did we speak to
them about? Do you remember? Okay. I
just have pictures that say he spoke
with them and they reported
>> Yeah, so we didn't we didn't speak about
Islam. We spoke about we spoke about the
Bible the deity of Christ. We didn't
speak about Islam. That's fine, but I I
just don't want to speak with you. Why?
That's like that's my question when you
have ask a Muslim why don't you want to
talk to a Christian? I understand, but
people have already spoken with you
online.
What does that have to do with you
holding a conversation here and your
job? I believe that you are not sincere
so I just want to
>> In what way? In what way am I not
sincere?
There are people online that have spoken
to you. You guys there's been debates.
That's fine, but I just don't want to
speak to you. You said I feel that See,
I feel that
there are people online they've already
answered your points and we don't need
to discuss them. Answered what points
specifically because on Jesus being a
Muslim you feel like that was answered?
Well, as Muslims we believe that
Jesus, right? He submitted his will to
God and that's exactly what he did.
>> But so so there's there's contention
there cuz I I understand that that's the
usual definition, right? That, you know,
people who submit to one God, that's
what a Muslim is. But, if I obviously I
believe that I submit to one God, I'm a
Christian, I believe Jesus is God, you
wouldn't say that I'm a Muslim, right?
So, it's it's There's There's It's not
as simple as that. There's more nuance
to that, right? You have to have the
right concept of God in order to be a
Muslim, you know? And so, I think that
um I don't think it's on purpose, but I
think that just saying Jesus is Muslim
is very misleading because you're not
saying it's not just believing in one
God. That's not all it takes. Would you
agree? Well,
Muslims, there's six articles of faith.
One of them is believing in one God.
Yeah. Another one is
Believing in the angels, the messengers,
uh predestination, I think. Uh The last
day. Mhm. Day of judgment, divine
decree. Yeah. Um
Yeah, what's up, bro? How's it going?
>> [laughter]
>> Peace be upon you as well.
No, it's us.
Yes, so those are Yeah, go ahead, those
articles. So, as Muslims we believe that
all the messengers of God, they brought
the same message. Mhm. Yeah. Worship one
God,
Yeah. and to not associate partners with
God, to obey God, right? Yeah. So, in
that essence, right, we don't believe
that
Jesus even brought a a different sort of
message Yeah.
So, in that
kind of logic, we believe that Jesus
>> No, thank you.
Appreciate it. a Muslim as well. But, in
the Bible, like I said, Jesus said
to that he submitted as well to God. He
also said the most important commandment
is hear, O Israel, the Lord our God, the
Lord is one. Mhm. Right? Mhm. The same
way the Muslims say, right? And Jesus,
like I have in the banner, Jesus said
the only true God is the Father,
That's That's That's important. Can I
Can I touch on that? Yeah. So, the
reason why that's important is because,
like I was saying, like, let's say I
believe I believe in one God who sent
messengers, I believe in the last day, I
believe in predestination, I believe in
the angels, right? And I believe in the
books,
right? But, when I say I believe in one
God, the God I'm talking about is Jesus
Christ. You would say that I'm not a
Muslim because I have the wrong concept
of the one God, right? So, I can fulfill
all of those criteria, but if I have the
wrong concept of who God is, I failed
the criteria being a Muslim. So, to be a
Muslim, the God I have to believe in is
specifically the God that's described in
the Quran. Would you agree with that?
Yes, but when Jesus says the only true
God is the Father,
>> Yeah. is does that mean Jesus is God?
Well, that's a different subject. I can
I That's the point you just touched on.
No, no, no, no, I'm I'm not talking
about the deity of Christ. Let me grant
that he's not God, right? I'm saying
that he's
>> Jesus worship then? The the Father. So,
so,
what I'm saying is that you don't have
to believe that you're God in order to
be a Muslim, right? You would If you
believe you're God, you're not a Muslim,
right? Let's grant for the sake of
argument that Jesus is not God. I'm
talking about what Jesus believed about
God, what he taught about God. And so,
one of the most important things about
Islam, for example, is that Allah has no
children, right? He doesn't begin nor is
he begotten, he has no sons, we are his
servants and slaves.
With Jesus, he says, like you said, the
one true God is the Father.
That's obviously not Allah,
unless you're saying that Allah is the
Father.
So, do you see like where there's a
condition there?
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, it's so it's fun stuff, man. It's
fun to do this in person. It's better
getting in person dialogue than just the
online people cuz people online can be a
little different, you know, but I like
in person connection. I mean, I saw so
many of your videos where you debated so
many people in like California and all
over the place. And then one of our guys
texts on the group chat, he's like,
"Avery's at Columbus State." I literally
I was here. I drove to Columbus State so
I could
Yeah? [laughter] Yeah, that was funny.
Let me shake your hand again, bro.
I never got your name. Abdel. Adil. Yes.
What does it What does that mean? That's
nice. It means the just and the kind
Arabic. Nice.
>> to live up to it though. Yeah. It's a
big name in one of the names of Allah.
Nice. What one of my Some of my Muslim
friends, they said
cuz like we we have our discussions all
the time, but like I'm very like nice
with them. They said that if I was a
Muslim that they would name me Abdul
Latif.
>> [laughter]
>> Which I think it means like servant of
gentleness or something like that.
But yeah. So So So going back, so like
so Jesus says that the one true God is
the Father.
This would mean that either Allah is his
father or he's has a different concept
of God than what's taught in Islam.
Right? So
the point I'm trying to make
not essentially that Allah is the Father
or anything like that. I'm saying that
if there is Father, Son, and Holy Spirit
and Jesus says Jesus is a person of the
Trinity, right? That That's our belief,
but that's That's not relevant to the
conversation.
>> about John 17:3. Sure. So if Jesus is a
person of the Trinity, right?
>> Mhm. And you have the Holy Spirit, he's
a person of the Trinity. Yeah. And the
Father's a person of the Trinity. Yeah.
And Jesus, one of the persons of the
Trinity, says
to the Father that you are the only true
God, then that automatically discludes
them from being the true God. It It
doesn't, but again, that's another
That's another discussion cuz my
brother, I'm not talking about right now
whether or not Jesus is God. I'm talking
about whether or not he's a Muslim. You
know what I'm saying? So I'm saying that
Jesus he did not if he himself is not
God and he worshipped the Father Mhm.
right? In essence, he worshipped that
one God. All right, so let me go with
you. Let's say that Jesus is is not
Let's say he's worshipping the Father,
which I agree. He worshipped the Father.
I would say in our paradigm, the Father
also worships and glorifies the Son. It
goes both ways. But just for this
conversation, Jesus worships the Father.
Can you be a Muslim and claim to be the
Son of Allah?
Right. So if Jesus is saying that the
Father is the only true God, then that
disqualifies him from being a Muslim.
Right. But, what does it mean to be the
son of God? It doesn't matter. Like so
That's the point.
>> Let me say why. Let me say why.
>> Son of God is not a biological son of
God. Sure. I I Well, I I I
I agree it's not biological cuz God's
not a biological being, but I don't
think it's metaphorical. But, let me
Let's go with this.
Is Allah a father in any sense? Does he
have sons in any sense according to
Islam?
Right. So, that's why I say it doesn't
matter. Like I'm not saying that to be
stubborn, but it doesn't matter what in
what sense you say God is your father.
In Islam, it's clear in no sense can
anybody be a son of Allah, whether it's
metaphorical, figurative, whatever. So,
however Jesus meant it, Islamically he
would be wrong. You know what I'm
saying? Yep. So, I'm saying like this
this a verse like that would disqualify
him from being a Muslim cuz his concept
of God is different from what is taught
in the Quran. I understand. But, what do
the people the people back then What did
they classify someone being a son of
God? What What was the reasoning for
calling someone a son of God? Again,
there were different senses in which you
could be the son of God. Jesus claimed
to be the begotten son. You have Israel
who's adopted as a nation as his son.
Angels are called sons of God. But,
David is called a son of God. The kings
of Israel called sons of God. So, you
have different senses throughout the
Bible where someone is a son of God.
But, the point is is that in none of
those senses is it correct cuz Allah
doesn't have sons in any sense. But,
it's metaphorical. It's not biological.
Even if Like I said, even if it's
metaphorical, it doesn't matter cuz you
not Allah doesn't have metaphorical
children. So,
being a son of God is in essence being a
righteous individual or pious
individual, one who obeys God, worships
God. It's not
anything out of the ordinary. If we take
If we take that definition, then there's
no problem, right, for Jesus being
called a son of God because he was a
righteous person. He was the one who
obeyed God, followed God. So so this is
my this is my problem, okay? Cuz I hear
you. Um the problem is is that Jesus
makes a distinction between a son of God
and a servant of God. Cuz a servant of
God
obeys God and does his will and stuff
like that. But the son is different. He
says that the slave or the servant
doesn't remain in the house forever, but
the son remains in the house forever.
And whoever the son sets free is free
indeed. So obviously there's a hierarchy
when it comes to sonship and
servanthood, right? Would you agree that
uh let's say a master of a household or
owner of a household
um his relationship with his son is
definitely higher than his relationship
with a servant. Would you agree?
Relationship with yes. So Jesus says, he
makes a distinction between sons and
servants, and he declares himself to be
a son of God or even says we can be sons
of God. So even if it's metaphorical, my
brother, so I'm saying
the the Quran doesn't allow for a
metaphorical father and son
relationship. You know what I'm saying?
And do And do we agree with that?
Um
I wouldn't say I have a complete answer
to that. Well, that's fair. I appreciate
your honesty.
>> Right. Um I know I know that
uh
for example, chapter 112 says Allah does
not beget nor is he begotten. I believe
that is talking in a physical sense.
Yeah, like it like it comes from his own
essence. Yeah. But in terms of
metaphorically, I don't have the answer
for you. So so there's a verse um in the
Quran that I think alludes to this
pretty pretty good cuz in it's in
chapter 19, Surah Maryam.
Uh verses 88 to 93. And so it's talking
about how they ascribe to Allah a son,
right? They say he has a son. And he
says they have uttered an atrocious
thing
to where the heavens rupture, the
mountains crumble, the earth shakes that
they say the most beneficial has a son.
Um far be it from him to for him to take
a son. And then he caps it off with this
in verse 93. He says, "There's none in
the heavens or the earth that can come
to the most beneficent except as a slave
or a servant." However you want to
translate the word.
So, this verse says that there's no way
that you can come to Allah
except as a slave.
So, that even eliminates a metaphorical
relationship of son and fatherhood. You
get what I'm saying? Yeah, what verse is
that? Let me read it again. Yeah, sure.
That was That was uh chapter 19
verse uh 93. Have you ever gone to a
seminary? I did not. I did not, no.
Good question, bro. I do want to go to
school for like I want to learn Greek. I
want to learn Hebrew. I also want to
learn Arabic. Bro, I tried to Let me
tell you, I tried to learn Arabic on
YouTube for like a day. Let me tell I
couldn't She showed me the I was like,
"Okay, there's the alif. There's, you
know, whatever."
She said, "Okay, now put finally alif in
the word." She put a word together. I
couldn't follow. I was like, "Yeah, I'm
done. I quit." I'm trying it right now.
I've been doing it for the past like 6
months. It's really hard. Yeah, it's
it's it's tough cuz it's completely
foreign to everything I know about
letters. Like I got to just just forget
everything I know about letters and just
do something different, you know?
>> do you get your knowledge of the gospel
from?
Um, reading it, reading scholarship,
um
commentaries, church fathers, you know,
and stuff like that. So, essentially
you've done the work of a seminary
student. You just haven't In a way,
yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I've I've I've
studied, man. I got books that I still
have to finish. I got books I got to
start, but there's a lot of books that I
that I've been reading that has helped
me a lot throughout the years, you know?
And then also listening to a lot of
scholarly like lectures and stuff like
that. It really helped a lot over the
years. So, for any like Christian or
Muslim that wants to study, would you
say to go to seminary or would you say
you can self-study and get to that
knowledge point? Because the risk of
that is like you could read works by
people who are trustworthy but you can
also read people who are not. Exactly,
yeah. You got Yeah, yeah. That That's
the thing, too. Is you got to be careful
who you're You pick up a book and that
person could be completely unreliable
using wrong sources. That's why you got
to um
you got to like when they put footnotes
you got to check those footnotes out,
those sources out. And so you can
verify. There's ways to verify. But just
It does take more work. Yeah. But um
I I I
I don't think seminary is bad at all.
Like you can go to seminary and learn if
that's what you want to do. Go to
seminary. Um if you don't have the funds
or whatever and you just want to just
get some books, learn like figure out
who's reliable. That's what I would say
to check that out. And there's
interpretations of things, too, right?
>> Yeah.
When you read something from the
original language
like translating something from Arabic
to English
you can't read the English and then
understand the meaning, right? So you
have to read the Greek and Hebrew. Yeah.
>> there a specific person whose
interpretation you kind of trust or do
you interpret it to yourself? Yeah, so
there's not a a specific person that I'm
like, "Okay, whatever they say I'm going
with every time." But you know, you We
got We have like church fathers. We got
uh certain Christian scholars that, you
know, uh we can compare to when we're
reading. We can compare, see what the
majority says and how they understand
the verses, the context. Um
and we can go that way. We got to also
use our discernment as well. So it's not
like I don't have a scholar that I'm
like, "Oh, if he says this then yeah,
that's that's it's you know, I'm sold on
it." type of thing.
Does Does the Christian faith have
scholars that people can generally turn
to? Yeah, yeah. They're They're They're
called church fathers. So yeah, they'll
be church fathers.
Um
yeah, like they can turn to the church
fathers and then you can compare what
one church father says with others and
see where
the consensus is or see where they
differ and kind of make a judgment.
Does Islamically we have like certain
teachers that you can turn to like like
scholars
>> Yeah, yeah.
Got the tafsir, Ibn Kathir in there. So,
do you know anyone in the Christian
faith that people generally Yeah,
there's people like Augustine, there's
people like Poly-
Polycarp, Justin Martyr's huge.
Uh I said it again?
No, no, no, not Constantine. No.
Constantine was an emperor. He wasn't
like a a theologian or nothing like
that.
But yeah, so yeah, we got quite a few.
Irenaeus, Ignatius, got a quite a few.
What about um
Athanasius.
I'm getting his name
Who's the textual criticism scholar?
Bart Ehrman? Uh he's an atheist.
But he used to be Christian before,
right? Yeah, he's but not not based off
of He left Christianity cuz of the
problem of evil. I thought he became
agnostic, if I remember. Yeah, yeah,
well, yeah, agnostic He goes by agnostic
atheist. So. That's contradictory. I
agree.
>> [laughter]
>> I agree, bro. Like one time there was a
atheist
Yeah, yeah, I agree. So.
Would you would you say Bart Ehrman's a
trusted source?
Um
not completely cuz like I think he's
he's good on his scholarship when it
comes to textual criticism.
But there's other people that has the
same level that disagree with him on
certain things.
Um when it comes to his theology he's
not a theologian. So, when he starts
making theological claims, like whether
or not the Bible teaches Jesus is God or
not, he's way off. So.
Depends on the area that you're asking
about.
Do you believe that there comes a point
where you can't preach to someone
before, right? Like
there's a verse in the Quran that says
So, tell oh Prophet Muhammad to the
disbelievers, for you is your faith and
for us is our Yeah, yeah, there comes a
point, yeah.
>> believe there's a point where you can
only preach to someone to some extent
before you realize that they've strayed
far away from Yeah, yeah, Jesus even
tells us when you just preach the the
to one town and they don't listen to
you, dust your hands and move on to the
next. So, we we we use the sermon he
even says do not cast your pearls before
swine. You give what is holy to the dogs
meaning like if the person is just
spiritually stubborn, like don't give
like stop wasting your time and energy.
You know, let let them go. So, it does
it does come to a point like that.
So, do you believe that there's a point
in our conversation today where
we can talk for only some extent before
we know that we've reached the end of
it? Not really. I mean unless you guys
are like so for example with this
brother here, so far he's been
intellectually honest with me, you know?
He hasn't been playing games. He's been
honest answering as best as he could.
So, that shows a genuineness even though
we disagree. So, I don't I the way that
he in his character he has honesty shows
that we can have these conversations and
like you know, he can make me think
about something. I can make him think
differently about something, you know?
So, he's he's shown openness to that.
Even talking to you right now, you
you're showing openness by even asking
me the type of questions and these are
good questions. You show openness to it.
So, but if you guys show dishonesty and
like you like don't care about the
explanations or not willing to think
about what I'm asking, then like yeah,
that's that's closed-mindedness.
Agreed absolutely. It goes both ways. If
a Christian is like that, dishonest, not
trying to really engage honestly and
genuinely, dust your hands off.
Can you post that part by the way?
>> [laughter]
>> Y'all heard that, right? You know.
Do you do you plan on speaking to any
Muslim apologetics
anytime soon cuz I know you spoke to
Sheikh Uthman. Daniel Haqiqatjou, I have
a debate with him in July. With Hamza?
No, not Hamza. He's
he's one of those guys I dust my hands
off.
He he the reason why is because he he
takes it beyond me and religion. Like he
made a video saying is is that my wife
is a
So, when you when you go that far you
cross that line,
you know, you dust your hands off. This
person is not someone you can talk to
cuz you're taking it personally.
So.
So, did you uh what you what you find?
So, this verse uh
this is like AI and I'm reading some
stuff here. Sure. But, it means every
being in the heavens and earth will
return to Allah
>> as a submissive servant. This is talking
about the day of judgment. So, when
people when the they're I know. I know.
when the people in the heaven not the
heavens, but the people on the earth
when they return to Allah I know. I
know. I know. they will return to him as
a submissive as a only as a servant. And
an an example I can give you is Ibrahim
alayhis salaam Abraham I know. I know.
he is called Khalil Allah. What does
that mean? It means a friend of
[laughter] Allah. Is that not That's
also a metaphor for or a relationship
that he has with Allah. Right? Like on
the day of judgment, he will also return
as a servant to Allah the Almighty.
Okay. So, uh you said that was an AI
explanation? It is called AI
explanation, but Islam is the one true
religion.
So, can I tell you why I disagree with
that? Go ahead. Also, last
>> So, the reason why I disagree with that
is because in context it's not talking
about anything about judgment day. The
context is talking about Allah having a
son, the relationship he has with
creation.
You know? And so, it says
All right. That's So, that's next. So,
that's that's a completely different
context.
>> Right. What he's saying
So, this is this is Surah Maryam, right?
So, when he says there's no one on the
heavens and the earth that he comes to
the most merciful as a servant and he
has enumerated them counting them a full
counting. And all of them are coming to
him on the day of judgment. We're
talking about coming to him. Talking
about the day of judgment. Yeah, but
that's that's another verse. That's
that's an two verses later.
So, what what I'm saying is is that's in
addition to what he already said. So,
one, there's none that can come to him
except as a slave, yada yada yada, and
everyone's going to return to him on
judgment day, right?
Exactly. So, I'm not saying that's
negating that.
Huh? When do people come to Allah? Don't
you go to Allah in your prayers? Yes,
but when he's talking about coming, it's
a physical coming.
How do you know that?
So, we'll come
The word is
Like I I understand the Arabic word is
to come, but like the context will
tell us if it's like
coming physically or coming like just in
relationship.
So, then So, then can I can I then make
that that case then that this is only
talking about Allah having a son in the
case of the day of judgment? That maybe
before before the day of judgment he has
sons, but only on the day of judgment he
doesn't have sons?
No.
Yeah.
No. So, I we we popped up here. We was
like walking around the campus just to
you know, let's see where everybody was
posted at. So, we started walking this
way, ran into a a Christian some
Christian students here. They said, "Oh
yeah, man. There's a There's a Muslim
group on the inside." No, first it was
the Muslims who told us. We I saw some
young Muslims like, "Hey guys, do you
want to talk about Muhammad?" They're
like, "Uh no, but there's a there's a
Muslim group on the inside. If you go
into this building, they'll talk to
you." Then the the Christian brothers
and sisters they showed us where to go.
So, it was it just worked out.
Huh?
We're going to Dearborn. So, um we came
visited
the uh them first.
Started to do some outreach out here at
the colleges.
But our main our main event is Dearborn,
Michigan today uh tomorrow.
Just uh going to the neighborhoods, the
masjids, and trying to get conversations
with some imams, some sheikhs, see if
some knowledgeable people would talk to
us.
the tour on the touch screen. I mean,
I'm not going to like go after him, but
if he Let's say if I'm in San Diego
again and he's there, I'll talk to him.
But You went to his masjid, right? Huh?
You went to his masjid, but he wasn't
there?
Yeah.
Yeah, some of the Muslims invited me.
So, what you got?
Okay, verse 87.
None will have the power of
intercession. Do you know what
intercession is? To pray for someone
else. You know, intercession like on the
day of
day of judgement like someone can
basically say uh
say something for you on their on their
on their behalf. Like Yeah, to pray for
someone for to pray for someone else,
right? But you're But you're saying it's
specifically day of judgement?
>> Yes, it's intercession.
So
First it says on the day we'll gather
the righteous. So, on the day meaning
the day of judgement, right? And we will
drive the criminals to hell with thirst.
None will have the power of
intercession. So, this is obviously
talking about the day of judgement
except
he who had taken most from the most
merciful of common
And they say, so it's talking about
these people.
Right, so so the conversation switches
from what he's going to do on the day of
judgement, right?
>> But who is it who says this? The the
people who are like uh disbelievers,
hypocrites probably. on the day of
judgement. So so all of this is on the
day of judgement.
>> No, no, but they
They say on the day of judgement. So, on
the day of judgement they'll say the
most merciful has taken a son. Wait, so
they don't say that now and they
currently? They say it currently, but
he's saying on the day of judgement.
Right, but now Allah is saying you've
done an atrocious thing. The heavens and
earth almost rupture from their
statements, right?
>> Okay. And they attribute to the most
merciful a son. So, let's talk about
currently. It is not appropriate.
Look look, brother, look. If I You You
Ibn Kathir? You follow like tafsir and
stuff like that? Like content? This
I I'm I It's been a long time since I
looked at what he says, but
if I
I think it's current.
Let's go to 88.
Let's see.
So, 88 to 95 he says the stern rejection
of attributing a son to Allah
after Allah affirms in this noble surah
that Isa was a worshiper and a servant
of Allah and he mentioned his birth
without a father. He then begins
refuting those who claim that he has a
son. Holy is he and far exalted is he
above such description. Allah says so
and this is starting in verse 88. So,
he's talking about the current claims,
not what they would claim on judgement
day.
Uh I I see I I look cuz I I I see why
you say like don't don't think that I'm
not I'm stubborn. I see why you're
saying that because it's talking prior
about the day of judgement. So, I see
how you're getting that. My my my thing
is that I feel like this
this section of him talking about the
sonship is is is a general
rejection directed at the people in that
time that's still claiming that he has
children, that he has a son, you know?
So, I wouldn't relegate it to just
judgement day, but also the people
that's there in Muhammad's time saying
that Jesus is the son of Allah or
others.
Except as a slave, yeah. Uh-huh. So, I'm
saying that that is only on the day of
judgement that they come to him as a
servant and a slave. Okay, so why can't
they come to Allah as a metaphorical
son?
A metaphorical son? Mhm. Well, because
in this verse it says when they come to
Allah on the day of judgement, they come
to him as a slave. Right, so so this
this disregards any type of sonship
relationship whether it's metaphorical,
literal, figurative, whatever. He He
rejects any sense of sonship to him on
this on this in this day, right?
So, that's what I'm saying. So,
if you're teaching that God is your
father in any sense, he's saying no cuz
you can only come to him even on this
day
as a servant, not as a son. Was Jesus a
servant of God? He's
uh it's a good question. So, this is
what I'm You You would agree that sons
like children are servants of their
parents, right?
Right. So, yes, Jesus is a was a servant
of God, but he wasn't merely a servant.
He was also his He claimed to also be
his son, which takes it a step further
with the relationship.
Just as Abraham was a servant of God,
he was also a friend of God.
That's what the Quran says. So, it's not
Abraham is not going to come on the day
of judgement being a friend of God. He's
going to be a servant of God. So, so do
you So, do you believe that when Abraham
returns to Allah, that on the day of
judgement he's still his friend?
He was regarded as a friend, but he
returns to him as a servant. But, is he
is is he also both though? Not just
merely a servant, but he's also a
friend? On the day of judgement,
according to this verse I feel no, but
I'm not 100% educated to give you a
scholarly level of response. Could Could
it be possible if we're if we're to give
being charitable, could it be possible
that Abraham would be an exemption to
the rule an exception to the rule?
Does God have a He had a special
relationship with him?
Many prophets had different
relationships with like Moses spoke
about it, but Abraham never spoke to
God, right?
>> Right.
That is
Jesus was a spirit from Allah, right?
That's another thing. The prophet
he met he went to the heavens, right? On
the night journey. Yeah. So, each
prophet has a different relationship
with God.
Say that one is an exemption, but I
don't think that makes sense.
Okay. So, Abraham can only return to
Allah as a servant, not even a friend.
No one can return to Allah except as a
servant. And so,
return to Allah on the day of judgment.
Right. So, in So, this is what it seems
to me.
We have a rejection of
um
having any any children throughout the
Quran.
We have an explicit rejection of any
sense that he has sons when you return
to him on the day of judgment. Um
according to Ibn Kathir, he seems to be
addressing even the people rejecting
them
in that time as uh people having uh
saying Allah has sons. So,
it seems like the Quran is clear that
there is in there is no way where Allah
has children or he has sons. In no way,
shape, or form. And to say that you have
a that you are a son of Allah or a
daughter of Allah in any sense would be
going against Islam. Would you agree?
I don't know about metaphorically,
because like like I said before, what
does it mean to be a
Okay. Like biological or
like something like that.
>> Can I Can I show you that Allah rejects
even metaphorical? Cuz I Cuz that would
be one of them. There's another one.
Yes.
Yes, so now
Now, with the Jews, for example,
the Jews also claim to be sons of Allah,
his loved ones.
So,
and then he says um
Well, you got the Quran open. It's uh
chapter five.
So cute. You [laughter] wrote it, huh?
You got to try to pull some clips
anyway, huh? I see how it is. That's a
cute little one.
>> [laughter]
>> Uh okay, let's hilarious.
He said he said he wasn't actually
saying that.
Huh? No, I didn't. You said that, right?
No, I didn't.
No, you said that you talked to us and
we said we never talked to you. Okay.
So,
in chapter
What is that?
Sorry, we have
There's a rule in the university that we
have to be behind the table and we have
so many people in front of the table.
We have so many people in front of the
table. We just have to make sure that
they're, you know,
>> So, what can we do?
To be honest,
we're trying to figure that out because
we got a warning before. We don't want
to get kicked out. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, well well, if you need me to tell
them anything to spread out or
something, just let me know. I have a
question for you, though.
Are you Are you Do you ever think you're
going to become Muslim? No. Never? I I
feel like I know
too much to become Muslim. There's too
many problems for me, you know. So, then
you would you would never worship what
we worship and you would never worship
what you worship, right? So, would you
believe there's a point to this
conversation? Yeah, cuz there's a
possibility that your minds could be
changed.
You know, as it's happened like I've
I've had these conversations where, you
know, I'm I'm speaking with devout
Muslims and they change their minds, you
know? So, there's always a chance. You
never know.
So, then do you keep that chance for
yourself as well?
Uh no, there's there's no possibility
for me.
But you you would tell the Muslims to
have an open mind, right? Like be
sincere. Yeah, this is what I'm saying.
I'm saying I have an open mind, but
because of like I I'm open to the truth.
If something is objectively false,
I it's false. I can't like fix my mind
to try to accept something that's that
I've
seen that is false like objectively, you
know, not because of my bias or anything
like that, you know?
So,
yeah, so I'm not I'm not saying that
Islam is false cuz I'm just oh I'm a
Christian I'm against Islam.
The the
what I I've read the Quran. I've read
Hadith. You know, I I've read the entire
book of destiny in Sahih Muslim. Like I
sat on my couch just scrolling and just
reading each Hadith, you know,
in in that particular book
that chapter.
So it's like
I'm I'm not uneducated about what I'm
disagreeing with. You know what I'm
saying?
Look, here's what I say. If
if
my problems can be solved with that I
have with the Quran with Islam,
then that would open me up to it.
So like I I'm live all the time. I have
these discussions. So I'm open to
someone refuting the issues that I have
and I can change my I've changed my mind
before. You know, I've used the argument
before, bro, and a Muslim a
knowledgeable Muslim said, hey man, this
is this this this. So this is why this
doesn't work. I said okay, yeah, I never
used it again.
Then I'm then I'm open to Islam being
true.
If it's true?
Yes.
It's not about that.
Yeah, so it's it's not about that.
No,
cuz you got you guys pray to a different
God.
You know, just like you could you
couldn't come into a church and pray
with me, could you?
No, cuz that that pretense is like,
you know, or let's say we could I would
like we could pray at the same time. I'm
praying to to my God, you're praying to
Allah. We could do that, sure. But
yeah, no, man.
>> [laughter]
>> Yeah, we doing it. Look, you got you see
the smile on your face? 10 minutes and
then we'll come back.
>> Okay. Are you going to be here in 10
minutes? Sure. Yeah, we we can hang
well, it's let me it's up to Come on,
Ellie. This is like we're having the
best time here, you know. Honestly, we
are.
You guys have a table set up? Uh we're
going to eat. There's some people who
want to get get some food with us.
>> There's a cafe right there though.
Oh, they're they're like
they they got reservations for us. So,
it'll be kind of messed up if we flaked.
Um
>> It's so crazy though cuz I've watched so
many videos of you and then just having
you stand here personally
Is it is it different from what you've
seen in there?
It's more real. Mhm. You know, I like
that. They keep telling me to not delay
the prayer for Dallas, so come on. Yeah,
pray, bro.
>> [laughter]
>> But
I'll try to be right here, bro.
>> Come pray with us. I can't. Hey, stay
here until we come back. We'll be right
back. I'll see I'll I'll talk to the
group. We're going to get Take Take a
day.
Sure. Uh which one are the best? Oh,
this one says almond. I'll try almond.
>> Take all three.
Oh.
Okay.
Logic.
>> [music]
[music]